vous voulez acheter un smartphone en
octobre 2023 ça tombe bien je vais vous
aider je vais vous dire quel smartphone
venir choisir alors on va essayer de
compacter un peu cette vidéo pour
qu'elle soit beaucoup moins longue que
ce qu'on avait en septembre et au mois
de juin en dessous de 200 € j'ai reenu
deux smartphones qui m'intéressent ici
le premier ça va être le redmi note 12
4G et le Samsung Galaxy A14 4G ici je
vais vous recommander d'aller sur le
redmi note 12 4G pourquoi et bien parce
qu'ici vous avez un écran AMOLED amolet
c'est intéressant parce que vous aurez
des noirs profonds un pixel noir est un
pixel éteint donc quand c'est noir c'est
vraiment noir c'est aussi me pour
l'économie de la batterie de votre
smartphone tandis que chez Samsung vous
êtes sur un écran LCD ça veut dire quand
on est sur un pixel noir il est pas
éteint en fait il va vous fabriquer du
noir donc ça vient consommer dans les
deux cas c'est sensiblement la même
taille d'écran on a des capteurs de 50
mégapixel d'un côté comme de l'autre
mais soyons clair ici ça sera pas Dingo
le smartphone de Xiaomi va être un peu
plus cher à partir de 199,90 € chez
Samsung on est à 179 € si vous en avait
la possibilité mettez les 20 € de plus
pour aller sur le redmi note 12 4G on
arrive tout de suite audessus des 200 €
là on est dans l'univers des smartphones
5G chez Samsung on a le A14 5G le A23 5G
génération d'avant le A34 5g et le A54
5G alors pour vous expliquer très
rapidement la différence tous les écrans
ici ont une dalle de 6,6 pouces sauf le
A54 5G qui a une dalle de 6,4 pouces
c'est quasiment la même chose on est sur
tous les smartphones sur un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 Hz sauf sur le
A14 5G mais globalement ça Chang pas
grand-chose et en fait plus vous allez
monter en gamme et plus vous en aurez en
terme de performance entre guillemets
mais surtout au niveau de la photo dans
tous les cas vous avez un capteur de 50
mégapixel sauf sur le A34 c'est du 48
bon sur le A14 5G vous n'avez pas
d'ultra grand angle sur les trois autres
smartphone vous avez un ultra grand
angle et après tout ce qui va être macro
et capteur de profondeur on s'en fout
c'est pas terrible et en face de ça vous
avez les champions de chez Xiaomi avec
le redmi note 12 5G le redmi note 12 Pro
5g et le redmi note 12 Pro plus 5G aussi
alors je suis hypra transparent c'est
pareil au niveau du A14 et du A23 j'ai
pas forcément venir vous les recommander
pourquoi parce que ici aussi on est sur
des écrans LCD tandis que Xiaomi vous
propose directement des écrans AMOLED
donc je préfère aller sur de l'Amoled
ici à tarif quasiment équivalent donc si
vous avez un budget aux enentour des 260
€ on va aller sur le redmi note 12 5G à
partir de
269,90 € le processeur conviendra écran
molet 120 Hz c'est grand c'est beau 6,67
pouces partout chez Xiaomi la photo sera
pas Dingo ici soyons clair mais ça fera
le boulot sur le capteur principal alors
premier dans cette gamme de 200 à 500 €
ça va être le redmi note 12 5G deuxième
que je viens vous recommander ça se
passe si Honor on est sur le Honor Magic
5 Lite qui est un smartphone que je
trouve très joli avec son écran incurvé
c'est du ha LED 120 Hz et surtout il a
un tarif qui est extrêmement canon sur
le 6 128 on est à
299,90 € à moins de 300 balles
franchement ai ça fait vraiment le taf
même taille d'écran que chez Xiaomi 6,67
pouces 120 Hz capteur principale de 64
mégapixel c'est pas extraordinaire en
photo mais le boulot est bien fait 3oè
smartphone que je vais vous recommander
on retourne chez Samsung c'est le Galaxy
A54 5G on augmente un petit peu en
budget ici on est à 429 € et c'est un
super rapport qualité- prix écran Super
amolet de 6,4 pouces taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 Hz capteur
principal de 50 mgapixel ultra grand
angle de 12 mégapixel on a de la macro
en 5 mégapixel mais ça globalement on
s'en fout un peu oneui super expérience
Samsung IP67 bref je pas vous faire la
fiche technique mais c'est un très joli
produit qui est très polyvalent et qui
dans cette gamme de prix fera vraiment
bien la faire en face il y a le redmi
note 12 Pro plus 5G qui est aussi très
bien bon voilà ok un moment il faut
faire des choix il y a aussi un autre
smartphone qui est très cool qui est
déjà sorti derniè mais que je vous
recommande une fois de plus c'est le
noing phone one il est pas tout nouveau
mais je viens vraiment le repositionner
ici parce qu'il a un design très
particulier avec la gliff interface
derrière qui est juste magnifique si
vous ne connaissez pas ce smartphone
allez voir ma vidéo je vous mets bien
évidemment tous les liens pour les
smartphones pour pouvoir les acheter si
vous voulez et également pour pouvoir
voir la vidéo tous les liens sont en bas
dans la description je tiens à préciser
ici que tous les smartphones dont je
parle sont les smartphones que j'ai eu
entre les mains et que j'ai testé que je
connais donc je vais pas vous parler de
smartphone que je ne connais pas ce
smartphone là le nothing phone one il
est intéressant parce qu' il est
positionné au tarif de 399 €. j'aime
beaucoup ce produit on parlera du Laing
phone 2 un peu plus tard dans la vidéo
mais celui-là à ce tarif là franchement
il est canon j'ai aussi un autre
smartphone qui vient de sortir qui est
très sympa c'est le Motorola c'est le
edge40 Neo alors je suis en train de le
tester je suis en train de bosser dessus
j'ai fait quelques photos c'est toujours
un peu le problème de Motorola c'est que
les photos c'est pas foufou il faudrait
que les ingers de Motorola travaillent
un peu plus la partie photo par contre
là parce que c'est ça être un revêtement
probablement plastique mais qui est très
doux sous le doigt coloris Panton que
franchement j'aime énormément ils en
font pas trop il vous mettre deux
capteurs photo ils ont compris ça serv à
rien d'en mettre trois pour mettre un
capteur de merde donc ils l'ont pas fait
vous avez par contre un très joli écran
qui est incurvé sur le côté que moi
j'aime bien et que franchement ici je
peux venir recommander alors il vaut le
même prix que le dosing phone one il est
à 399 € par contre il a un atout qui est
vachement bien c'est que vous avez un
écran po LED 6,55 pouces ça vous me
direz ok mais surtout à 399 € vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement de 144 Hz
399 € ça va vraiment le coup et h
smartphone on est dans le haut du panier
on est à
499,90 € c'est le Honor 90 qui est un
très joli smartphone que j'aime beaucoup
que je vous ai déjà présenté alors
au-delà d'avoir une super note chez
dxark au niveau de l'écran bon ok on
comprendra très bien c'est vraiment un
très très très bon rapport qualité prix
avec plein de belles technologies qu'on
mis Honor ici à l'intérieur une
gradation PWM à 3840 r ça c'est pour
votre fatigue oculaire ça va éviter la
fatigue oculaire il y a énormément de
techno à l'intérieur vous avez un écran
amolet de 6,7 pouces 120 Hz avec un
capteur principal de 200 mgapixel et un
capteur ultra grand maro de 12 mégapixel
plus 2 mégapixel pour mode portrait mais
ça globalement on s'en fiche un peu et
je trouve qu'il est super bien très
fonctionnel très malin et ça une fois de
plus à un peu moins de 500 € donc ça
aussi pour moi ça vaut le coup on vient
monter en prix on arrive dans la
catégorie de 500 à 900 € alors là on a
le Xiaomi 13t pro à partir de
799,90 € tout de suite je peux pas vous
en parler j'ai pas eu encore l'occasion
de l'avoir entre les mains j'ai pas
encore eu l'occasion de le tester je
l'attends j'espère que Xiaomi me
l'enverra rapidement pour que je puisse
le recommander ou pas chez Xiaomi on a
égal ement le 13 le 13 pro le 13 ultra
et le problème c'est qu'en terme de
tarif il vient de se mettre juste en
face de Samsung là où dans l'entrée de
gamme il y a un vrai match et souvent
l'avantage va du côté de chez Xiaomi là
dans le plus haut de gamme c'est plus
complexe un Xiaomi 13 à quasiment 1000 €
a beaucoup de mal à se battre face à un
S23 qui a baissé en tarif est passé de
849 à 799 € donc on a quand même 200 €
d'écart ici il est évident que je vous
recommanderai le Galaxy S23 pareil pour
le 13 pro 1299 € on en parlera un peu
plus tard et le Xiaomi 13 ultra 1500
balles aujourd'hui il y a un ultra qui
me plaît énormément ça se passe du côté
de chez Samsung on en parle tout à
l'heure à 1159 € il est évident que
j'irai pas chez chez Xiaomi ici mais
plutôt chez Samsung on revient là-dessus
dans quelques instants are smartphone
qui arrive également que j'ai pas encore
eu le temps de prendre entre les mains
qui vient tout juste d'être annoncé
c'est du côté de chez Google avec le
pixel 8 et Pixel 8 Pro ça on en parlera
également dans la vidéo de novembre et
on en parle bien avant sur ma chaîne
youtube donc si vous voulez des infos ça
arrive très très rapidement sur ma
chaîne donc jetez un coup d'œil vous
allez voir on parle très bientôt de
Google par contre smartphone que je
viens vraiment vous recommander de
Google et bien c'est le pixel 7a qui est
top 509 € on est juste auudessus des 500
balles là vous avez comme dir Google un
smartphone sans compromis qui est très
bon au niveau de la photo qui est
totalement optimisé pour l'univers
Google donc si vous voulez vraiment
piloter votre domotique à la maison
venir supprimer quelqu'un sur une photo
grâce à la gomme magique tout ce que
vous propose Google et l'univers Google
et bien vous l'aurez ici avec ce
smartphone qui est excellent avec la
même plus que le pixel 7 et Pixel 7 pro
avec le realilton pour avoir la vraie
carnation au niveau de la peau bref
smartphone extrêmement intéressant à 500
balles franchement un autre smartphone
que j'oudrais vraiment vous recommander
si vous voulez un smartphone petit avec
un petit écran et bien c'est le zenfone
10 d'Asus qui est très bon qui fait très
jolies photos 799 €. l'avantage qu'il a
c'est que il tient vraiment bien en main
il est vraiment pas très très grand ça
je vous l'ai déjà présenté ce smartphone
je trouve supra cool donc si vous voulez
un petit format vous voulez pas un
énorme écran d'ailleurs regardez il y a
ma tronche ici et bien vous allez sur le
zenfone 10 de Asus vous serez absolument
pas déçu il a tout sous le capot c'est
un dragon 8 gen 2 très performant les
dernières technram les dernières techn
de stockage c'est vraiment une petite
bombe avec un écran de moins de 6 pouces
5,9 pouces c'est un écran AMOLED de chez
Samsung qui est juste topissime are
smartphone que j'aime beaucoup et je
vous parlais tout à l'heure du noing
phone one voici son grand frère le noing
phone 2 729 € un design qui est beaucoup
mieux fini que la première génération la
glyf interface entièrement
personnalisable bref un smartphone que
j'aime énormément et que je viens
vraiment vous recommander si vous voulez
un produit très designé que tout le
monde n'a pas avec plein de super
options et j'adore ce look il y a aucun
smartphone qui est fait comme le noing
phone aucun donc si vous aimez le noing
phone et si vous voulez un truc
différent vous pouvez y aller sans aucun
problème on parlait tout à l'heure de du
Samsung Galaxy S23 qui est un super
rapport qualité prix il faut savoir que
Samsung a annoncé un nouveau smartphone
c'est le S23 fe je connais pas le tarif
tout de suite mais il va pas tarder à
arriver dans le courant de l'année donc
bon tout de suite je peux pas vous en
dire plus on a dit fishtech mais je l'ai
pas encore pris en main donc quand je
l'aurai pris en main très bientôt et
bien je vous en parlerai donc on en
reparlera j'espère j'espère au mois de
novembre si vous voulez pas un
smartphone chinois si vous voulez pas un
smartphone coréen si vous voulez un
smartphone américain et bien il y a
Motorola avec deux produits qui sont
intéressants et et à la fois un peu dur
pourquoi le hedge40 et le Edge 40 pro
pour voir que sur le Edge 40 pro on est
à 899 € on sera pas au niveau d'un
Galaxy S23 qui lui sera à 799 € donc là
ça va être compliqué de vous recommander
le hedge40 pro quant au hedge40 qui est
à 599 € en photo il va se faire éclater
par un pixel 7a maintenant ces
smartphones ils ont des avantages non
négligeables c'est les taux de
rafraîchissement au niveau des écrans
sur le H 40 on est à 144 Hz et sur le
hedge40 pro on est à 165 Hz donc si vous
cherchez beaucoup de fluidité pour
maximiser votre expérience de gaming on
peut aller là-dessus autre smartphone
que je vous recommande et que j'aime
beaucoup c'est Honor avec son Magic 5
Pro jusqu'au mois dernier il était dans
la catégorie des plus de 1000 € auord la
BA BC on est un peu en dessous des 1000
balles
999,99 € regardez c'est écrit ici et ce
smartphone c'est une petite Tury il va
être supérieur au Galaxy S23 et pour moi
c'est un vrai concurrent du Galaxy S23
ultra en photo il est est extraordinaire
l'écran est incroyable enfin c'est
vraiment un mes gros coup de cœur de
cette année il est pour moi un peu en
dessous du Galaxy S23 ultra mais là à un
peu moins de 1000 balles ça vaut
vraiment le coup donc si vous avez un
budget de 1000 € et que vous voulez un
super smartphone sur Android avec un
écran de 681 pouces qui va éviter la
fatigue oculaire avec un écran
antiintillement 1 milliard de couleurs
très lumineux de très jolies photos avec
un triple capteur 50 mégapixel le
dernier processeur le plus puissant du
moment le Snapdragon 8 gen 2 grosse
batterie wifi 6 bref un smartphone top
et et bien le Honor Magic 5 Pro est
probablement fait pour vous parce qu'il
est vraiment super canon et là Honor a
fait un effort au niveau du tarif ça ça
me plaît autre marque dont je vous ai
pas parlé depuis longtemps et donc je
voulais vraiment vous parler c'est
crossc crossc qui revient avec un tout
nouveau smartphone c'est le Stell X5 il
vient tout juste d'être annoncé alors
vous me direz monsieur gr tu es bien
marrant tu nous en parles mais tu l'as
pas eu entre les mains et ben c'est pas
vrai parce qu'en fait crossc m'a
gentiment proposé de venir faire
l'animation de leur vidéo de lancement
donc je suis descendu chez eux à ex en
Provence je l'ai eu pendant 3 jours
entre les mains on a vécu plein
d'aventures et je vous assuré que c'est
une proposition qu'on retrouve pas
illeurs qui est très intéressante c'est
très niché comme smartphone ce
smartphone là il reste dans l'univers de
crossc avec un smartphone très résistant
on peut le tomber l'échapper le faire
tomber il va dans la flotte partout il y
a aucun problème il est plus fin et plus
léger en design que ce qu'on connaissait
chez crossc avant c'est plus un
smartphone lifestyle résistant de chez
crossc avec deux boutons d'action donc
un bouton pour venir déclencher des
photos vous pouvez complètement
verrouiller l'écran donc vous allez sous
la phot je l'ai fait je suis parti
plonger avec eux je peux vous assurer
que tu dans la hou dans les calang céit
assez marrant vous descendez dessous
vous avez un bouton vous verrouillez
l'écran et ensuite vous avez bouton pour
venir prendre vos photos vous avez un
autre bouton qui vous permet de switcher
entre les modes photos vidéos portrait
et compagnie et un autre bouton qui vous
permet de switcher entre vos objectifs x
1 x 2 ultra Grand T selfie bref et je
trouve ça vachement bien c'est très très
malin donc c'est un vrai smartphone
passe partout que vous travaillez dans
les bureaux dans le BTP que vous
travaillez n'importe où que vous vouliez
un smartphone extrêmement résistant ben
franchement il est intéressant le
Steller X5 je peux le recommander en
plus de ça ce qui est cool c'est qu'il
le garantissent 5 ans mais vraiment 5
ans
899,90 € ça reste un certain budget get
mais c'est vraiment un très très très
très bon smartphone le design est cool
la matière est bien voilà c'est très
différent et surtout c'est un smartphone
français designé en France et rien que
pour ça ça vaut le coup et après bien
évidemment qui on va voir on va voir
Apple ça fait vraiment un parallèle par
rapport à ce que j'avais dit le mois
dernier j'ai encore les tarifs je vous
avais dit on attend on va pas tout de
suite chez Apple on attend parce que les
tarifs vont baisser et c'est vrai 529 €
vous avez l'iPhone se le vrai bon coup à
faire c'est l'iPhone 13 qui était
regardez j'ai mes tarifs là de du mois
dernier il était à 909 € il est passé
c'est à 749 € on a eu 150 € de Rabé en
quelques jours donc ça vait vraiment le
coup d'attendre on a aussi l'iPhone 14
qui était à partir de 1019 € et que là
on retrouve à 869 € pareil Apple a
vraiment joué le jeu en maîtrisant ces
tarifs ils les ont diminués les iPhones
coûtent moins cher cette année en 2023
qu'il le coûtait encore il y a quelques
mois ou l'année dernière et puis bien
évidemment l'iPhone 15 le fleuron
d'Apple à partir de 969 € donc si vous
voulez un excellent smartphone alors moi
j'ai ici le plus c'est la même histoire
entre le plus et l'iPhone 15 et puis
après on passe dans les smartphones à
plus de 1000 € là ça va être vite vu
vous avez chez Samsung le Galaxy S23
plus 1059 € et le S23 ultra 1159 €.
soyons clair le S23 plus on va pas
l'acheter si on a 1000 € à mettre on
rajoute 100 balles de plus et on va sur
le S23 ultra qui est une petite tuerie
j'adore réellement ce smartphone et pour
moi ça reste quand même mon chouchou
pour l'instant et comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure ce Galaxy S23 ultra et
bien il fait tellement nombre à Xiaomi
c'est compliqué de venir vous
recommander un Xiaomi 13 ultra à 1500
balles ou encore un Xiaomi 13 pro à 1299
€ il est moins cher celui-là le Galaxy
S23 ultra et puis bien évidemment on va
finir ensuite avec les iPhone 15 avec
l'iPhone 15 plus 1119 € et si vous en
avez la capacité on va aller sur les
modèles pro avec le dos en titane qui
est quelque part par là l'iPhone 15 pro
max il est absolument cool je vous ai
fait une vidéo d'ailleurs où j'ai
comparé en photo le Galaxy S23 ultra et
l'iPhone 15 pro max max allez voir ma
vidéo vous risquez d'avoir des surprises
vraiment mais sinon en terme de finition
c'est un smartphone qui est vraiment
magnifique on en parle aussi dans
quelques jours sur Youtube donc reste
connecté mais c'est vrai que au-delà des
1000 balles pour moi le coup de cœur ça
reste quand même celui-là ça reste le
Galaxy S23 ultra qui est un excellent
smartphone après une fois de plus la
différence va se faire entre le choix
d'os d'un côté iOS ou de l'autre côté
Android donc à mon sens à plus de 1000 €
il vous reste deux smartphones
aujourd'hui Galaxy S23 ultra iPhone 15
pro Max sont les deux les deux qui
restent il sont bien après on arrive
dans les smartphones qui vont se plier
ou celui que je vous recommande plus
plus plus plus plus c'est celui-là c'est
le Galaxy zflip 5 qui est topissim qui
est vraiment un excellent smartphone que
j'utilise en smartphone principal depuis
le mois de juillet que vraiment je vous
recommande énormément j'adore l'écran
extérieur il est top il est F il est
vraiment bien 1199 € ça reste un
certains budget mais il est exceptionnel
alors bien évidemment il y a aussi le ZF
de 5 qui est un smartphone plus niché
plus professionnel à presque 1900 € 1899
€ pas forcément celui-là je vais bien
vous recommander de toute façon si c'est
ce smartphone que vous voulez vous êtes
pas en train de regarder cette vidéo
parce que vous le savez donc vous avez
pas besoin de moi et puis il existe
aussi un smartphone qui est intéressant
et que j'aime beaucoup au niveau de
l'écran du côté de chez Motorola c'est
le Razer 40 ultra mais il coûte
exactement le même prix que le Galaxy Z
fliip 5 donc ici à tarif équivalent je
préféis le Galaxy zfilp 5 que je vais
trouver meilleur au niveau des finition
même si j'aurais bien aimé que Samsung
Vienne un peu plus bas là voyez vous
mettre un écran au niveau de cette
partie Caméra Café Motorola bon c'est
comme ça je voudrais qu'on se parle de
gaming maintenant avec quelques
smartphones qui m'intéressent vous allez
voir il y en a quasiment pour tous les
on va commencer chez poco avec le poco
X5 5G qui est un smartphone qui débute à
249,90 € soyons clair chez poco les
modèles que j'ai testé n'était pas fou
en photo donc ce qui nous intéresse
réellement c'est la performance la très
belle performance d'ailleurs avec ici
Snapdragon de la série 6 685 très bien
écran Full HD plus amolette 120 Hz taux
d'échantillonnage tactile 240 Hz on se
parle ici d'une dalle de 6,67 pouces et
vous avez une proposition qui est
vraiment super intéressante avec ce
smartphone mais il y a également un
smartphone un peu au-dessus c'est le le
modèle professionnel qui commence à
299,90 € c'est aussi très bien
positionné on arrive cette fois-ci sur
la série 7 de Qualcomm avec un Sandragon
778g on garde un écran AMOLED toujours
6,67 pces Full HD plus 120 Hz ici de la
charge turbo 67 W ça charge très vite
alors que sur le poco X5 5G vous avez de
la recharge 33 W donc vous voyez on a
deux positionnements vraiment
intéressants ici et après on peut encore
venir monter en gamme puisque j'ai testé
dans la série F les F5 et F5 pro je
trouve intéressant aussi à partir de
399,90 € là on monte tout de suite en
gamme au niveau du processeur Série 7
toujours mais Snapdragon 7 plus gen 2 on
garde cet écran de 6,67 pouces 120 Hz
toujours de la recharge 67 W pour moi il
y a une très très belle proposition ici
avec un pros qui est gravé en 4 nanomè
vraiment de la très très belle
performance technologie liquid cool 2.0
pour le refroidissement technodram on a
ce qu'il faut l' lpdd5 on a du stockage
en ufs 3.0 bon ça va c'estz rapide c'est
efficace donc il a vraiment ce qui
convient sous le capot l'extension
dynamique de RAM bon ok on passe et puis
bien évidemment le modèle presque ultime
et qui est très très bien chez poco le
F5 pro on arrive carrément sur un des
meilleurs processeur du marché le
Snapdragon 8 plus gen one à un peu moins
de 600 balles
579,90 € on a pour le coup un écran 2K
donc on va un peu plus haut que les
autres modèles toujours 120 Hz de lachge
rapide 30 W c'est un peu moins vite la
photo je vous disici on s'en fout faut
vraiment retenir qu'ici vous avez un
smartphone qui va être sans concession
avec du refroidissement avec des techn
de RAM qui vont très bien la même chose
que sur le F5 F5 F5 pro lpddr5 ufs 3.0
la technologie d'extension de RAM
dynamique ça aussi c'est cool bref c'est
un smartphone qui va très bien donc donc
pour expérience gaming un tarif maîtrisé
je dirais que chez Poku il y a vraiment
ce qui va bien et après si on veut le
l'expérience ultime en terme de gaming
sur smartphone on va avoir des
accessoires on va avoir un smartphone
qui est pensé construit autour du gaming
on va chez Asus avec le rock Phone 7 qui
commence à 129 € c'est tout de suite
beaucoup plus cher mais par contre ce
que vous avez ici vous le retrouverez
nul par ailleur déjà un design très trés
typé Snapdragon 8 gen 2 qui va
extrêmement bien il y a beaucoup de
performance vous avez un écran Samsung
AMOLED 165 Hz au niveau du taux de
rafraîchissement vraiment ça déconne pas
une très grosse batterie de 6000 mamph
et puis vous savez l'expérience gaming
c'est pas uniquement des couleurs c'est
pas uniquement des specs c'est aussi une
expérience globale ici vous avez ce
qu'on appelle les air triggers qui vous
servent à venir utiliser la partie
dessus de votre smartphone pour avoir
des commande supplémentaire là l'audio
est vraiment super bon le smartphone est
génial allez voir ma vidéo si vous êtes
intéressé par ce smartphone et si vous
connaissez pas il a vraiment tout ce qui
va bien un système de refroidissement
qui est aussi incroyable un design à
couper le souffle bref pour l'expérience
ultime de gaming c'est le Asus rock
Phone 7 alors après il y a d'autres
modèles il y a le ultimate et company
mais c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus
cher c'est déjà un certain budget
personnellement j'aime beaucoup très
grand écran de 6,78 pouces bref voyez
que pour le gaming etci il y a aussi
vraiment ce qu'il faut voilà pour cette
sélection d'octobre j'espère qu'elle
vous aura intéressé et allez jeter un
coup d'œil à ma vidéo avec un vrai fight
entre d'un côté le Galaxy S23 ultra et
l'iPhone 15 pro max vous m'en direz des
nouvelles